خطط طوكيو لمضاعفه نفقه الدفاع تجر عليها
انتقادات موسكو بعد تلك التي تعرضت لها من
بكين روسيا اتهمت اليابان بالتخلي عن
سياستها السلميه المستمره منذ عقود
والاتجاه نحو العسكره الجامحه الخارجيه
الروسيه قالت انه من الواضح ان طوكيو شرعت
في مسار تعزيز قوتها العسكريه بصوره غير
مسبوقه بما في ذلك امتلاك القدره على
توجيه ضربات موسكو اعتبرت ان مثل هذا
التحرك سيثير حتما تحديات امنيه جديده
وسيؤدي الى تصاعد التوتر في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ الخطه الدفاعيه اليابانيه
تبلغ قيمتها 320 مليار دولار وستجعلها
صاحبه اكبر ثالث انفاق عسكري في العالم
بعد الولايات المتحده والصين العلاقه بين
موسكو و طوكيو متوتره بسبب النزاع حول
ارخبيل الكره
منذ انطلاق العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
ومتى لا ذلك من انضمام اليابان لشركائها
في مجموعه السبع في فرض عقوبات ضد موسكو
التطورات تاتي في ظل التوترات التي تعرفها
من طاقه المحيط الهدا في ظل استمرار
التهديدات الصينيه بغزوه تايوان السعيه
للاستقلال ما يفتح باب ازمه جديده في هذا
الركن من الكوكب تماما كما حدث في
اوكرانيا
بلال البوجدين العربيه